[Aplausos]
meu nome é carol levy
eu sou cantora e contadora de histórias
mãe e menina é digo menina porque
mantenho a minha criança cesa me
proporcionou montão de coisas inclusive
estar aqui hoje conversando com vocês
antes de fazer o que eu faço hoje contar
histórias para crianças e cantar e já
fiz uma porção de coisas
sou formada em publicidade e propaganda
já trabalhei em agências de publicidade
já trabalhei como analista de marketing
de uma grande rede de hotéis já tive
loja de moda
já fui morar em são paulo para trabalhar
com produção de eventos 77 é mas eu
fazia tudo e não estava satisfeita
me sentia sem propósito na vida infeliz
inquieta
fui parar na terapia claro que achava
que está ficando maluca né
luiza muito obrigada porque eu me sentia
um é te me observando no meio das
pessoas e as pessoas trabalhando numa
boa e eu nunca nunca nunca satisfeita
quando eu casei
o pobre do meu marido pode testemunhar a
minha angústia de perto porque estava
fazendo a última coisa que fiz antes de
fazer o que faço hoje
eu escolhi falar disso aqui porque eu
acredito que todo mundo tem um talento
aliás mais de 1 e que pra gente
descobrir quais os nossos talentos é
preciso olhar pra dentro e observar que
as nossas vocações estão nos mínimos
detalhes de nossas vidas começando lá na
nossa criança parece um clichê mas eu
acho a mais pura verdade
se nós conseguirmos pegar um pouquinho
da essência assim do que a gente é e
colocar no nosso trabalho
a vida seguia mais leve se nós desde
jovens naquela fase difícil de escolher
o que fazer da vida
pudéssemos ter o discernimento e nos
observássemos melhor pudéssemos nos
escutar
acho que conseguiremos grandes
oportunidades desde cedo
dito isso eu vou contar como tudo
aconteceu
estava eu e meu marido fechando a tal
loja de moda e eu a me desesperar
imaginando que eu ia ter que fazer
alguma coisa das coisas que fazia antes
né
só em pensar que ela tinha calafrio eu
não queria isso eu tinha certeza
com exceção da música eu não queria
fazer absolutamente nada do que eu já
tinha feito antes mas o que danado eu ia
fazer eu não sabia o que fazer e aí eu
resolvi fazer um pouquinho de cada coisa
que eu gostava de fazer aquelas coisas
que a gente faz e não sente o tempo
passar
pois bem eu não tenho uma banda nova
fiz curso de teatro fiz curso de desenho
artístico e desenho gráfico mantém um
portfólio com as minhas opções dublagens
e jingles publicitários que fazia montão
de coisas né
mas eu fui fazendo tentando
experimentando pra ver onde aquilo ia
dar e não dá em nada
não deu em nada mais me ajudou um bocado
eu vou explicar por que estava eu em
casa numa tarde fazendo os exercícios de
desenho artístico quando resolvi parar
para descansar abril a revista folheando
a revista eu avistei uma matéria bem
pequenininha de canto
falando de uma moça que era contadora de
histórias
quando eu vi aquela matéria meu coração
bater mais forte que eu fiquei ansiosa
esperando meu marido chegar quando
chegou carlito já sei o que eu vou fazer
eu vou contar histórias vão pegar as
minhas voltas que eu sei fazer e vou
cantar meu máximo e aí vocês não
imaginam a cara de espanto que ele
recebeu a notícia né
casei com a mulher errada também vem ano
convenhamos gente imagina em um mercado
de trabalho para os contadores de
história em 2010 ele não existia um
ofício da narrativa oral
mau era visto como um ofício aliás nisso
nós ainda estamos engatinhando mas eu
não vou entrar nessa seara
o foco da minha fala não é esse o que eu
quero dizer aqui é o que o que nós
vivemos custo constrói o que nós somos
mas a nossa essência desde cedo nos
empurra para o que podemos e o que para
onde podemos e devemos atuar
aquela coisa da essência que eu falei se
a gente conseguir botar um pouquinho ao
menos um pouquinho o nosso dia a dia e
aí meio que sem saber onde eu ia chegar
eu resolvi e atrás da tal contação de
histórias
comecei a estudar para entender onde
estava pisando os assuntos que eu tinha
que dominar e aí me deparei com a minha
primeira grande paixão e o meu primeiro
grande obstáculo
fiquei encantada com a literatura
infanto juvenil
os livros infantis são uma ferramenta
incrível para as crianças além
além de levar recursos gramaticais
maravilhosos para elas além de serem uma
excelente ferramenta de entretenimento
ludicidade aquelas páginas inofensivas e
coloridas são ferramenta de cura gente
um livro bem escrito ajuda as crianças a
passarem por problemas que aquelas
cabecinhas imaturas são tapas são
incapazes de elaborar bem maravilhoso
não desde que o narrador saiba lidar com
crianças
e foi aí que entra em pânico porque eu
não sabia lidar com crianças ou mental -
eu achava que não sabia mas mesmo assim
corria atrás fui lá
montei com o conhecimento que eu tinha
um banner coloquei nos elevadores do
prédio contação de história para levy e
até à hora tal salão de festas
me preparei achei procurei as melhores
histórias que eu considerava achei por
bem cantar um pouquinho vestir uma roupa
legal rezei e fui na data e hora marcada
chegando lá estavam as crianças me
olhando ressabiados esperando que eu ia
fazer
e quando eu comecei a falar com aquelas
crianças
quando eu comecei a contar histórias pra
elas a cantar a brincar com elas
parece que o tempo congelou
quando eu terminei já estava escurecendo
e as crianças continuavam lá comigo
felizes e leves e eu mais ainda porque
isso carol simples e watch v
a minha criança a menina que adorava se
apresentar para a família esperando os
aplausos
a menina cantora desde o coral da
infância a menina e odiava quando as
amigas em conta uma história maravilhosa
da forma mais sem graça possível no não
deixar que o koto pelo amor de deus
o adolescente que se entristeciam todas
as vezes que pensava na possibilidade de
não cantar quando quisesse e o
conhecimento àqueles anteriores o que eu
fiz com ele joguei no lixo
claro que não conhecimento nunca vai pro
lixo na gente então com as informações
que tive eu saí fazendo tudo para
divulgar o meu trabalho
criei um cartão de visita fiz um blog e
aí fiquei esperando ver se as pessoas
conhecerão também também fiz um vídeo
para que as pessoas entendessem que
danado fazer né
então depois disso eu planejei e planejo
tudo o que faz para as crianças de
acordo com o calendário anual
penso muito bem nos temas que estão
sendo abordados para as crianças para
que o poeta para que eu possa trabalhar
com eles
me sinto como uma voz uma ferramenta que
pode levar além muito além do
entretenimento
eu vim pra cá com o objetivo de falar
tudo isso pra vocês porque eu realmente
acredito que todos nós temos muitas e
muitas vocações
além disso tudo faltou uma coisa
as músicas as músicas se encaixam nas
histórias desde que as histórias
permitam as músicas e aquelas locuções
aquelas dublagens que eu falei viram
vários e vários personagens
ficou tudo junto e harmoniosamente
misturado
eu espero que vocês entendam que essa
questão da vocação é uma coisa que está
dentro da gente e aí eu vou lançar pra
vocês uma pergunta o que a sua criança
gostava de fazer
eu espero que a resposta os ajude com me
ajudou porque o ofício que eu escolher e
que me escolheu também reúne tudo que
sou poder contar histórias cantar para
as crianças dançar serelepe em cima de
um palco é de insatisfação sem tamanho
as coisas acontecem os desafios chegam e
enfrento eu encaro todos eles inclusive
estar aqui de uma forma leve como nunca
aconteceu na minha vida
hoje eu não imagino fazer outra coisa
que não senão que eu faço então é nisso
que eu acredito e eu espero que vocês
pensem nessa pergunta que eu lancei
porque eu realmente acredito que a gente
pode trabalhar com vocação amor e paz
isso sim ajudaria a gente é construir um
mundo melhor
obrigada
[Aplausos]